attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
même si la journée c'est lui qui m'a
aidé pour les raquettes arrêter là s'il
vous plaît halte là qu'est ce que j'ai
fait oh mais tu te fais choper
bah ouais j'étais entendre inquiéter
quelqu'un est là il m'a pris par
derrière moi c'est le coach attend plus
bas jamais par là - donc vous vous
connaissez oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est
lui qui m'a tout appris oui alors j'irai
pas jusque là non plus mais dont vous
êtes complices alors je vous embarque
aussi par contre j'ai pu me lot donc
vous me suivez on ne connaît pas un
allez on y va on fait les accents passer
la seconde parce que là on va y passer
la journée ici on attend dé moi je suis
mieux l'informatique n'a pas avec dedans
bon alors je reprends la situation des
faits l'agresseur agresser quelqu'un est
juste par curiosité il l'insulté ou pas
affirmatif
si noté dans le rapport finn moi ton
portable bape tout fragile mais quel con
mais c'est pourri et je les nomme jeudi
3 un truc plus percutant je suis
d'accord c'est complètement pour rien
allez donc vous êtes complice de
l'agresseur je vais donner deux trois
conseils pour aussillon en assurance oui
alors c'est vous cerveau du réseau ses
convives risqué pour ça monsieur
non dit toi rien parce que j'ai pas de
preuve mais quand même c'est pas gentil
ouais ouais
comment alors après vérification on fait
qu'ils m'envoient n'y est pour rien mais
pas que vous n'êtes pas venu porter
plainte après l'agression de l'agresseur
j'avais la flemme mais comme il n'a rien
volé je me suis dit je paniquais la
matinée puis toute façon même quand vous
les choper où les relâcher direct c'est
vrai pas donc vous allez même pas mis de
garde à vue talât n'ont rien fait mais
parce que j'aurais bien fait une garde à
vue au moins pour me raconter auprès de
mes pas dire je sois pas un gangster ou
non vous savez des gardes à vue
vous avez déjà entendu quelqu'un dans
les vestiaires d'une piscine oui bah
c'est pareil sauf que c'est son pack
l'ours sur la piste je vous montre
[Musique]